depuis le début de la pandémie l'
expertise des scientifiques a été
crucial épidémiologistes microbiologiste
virologues infectiologues neurologue
urgentologue leurs lumières nous ont
aidés à comprendre la pandémie et ses
conséquences
si la très vaste majorité de la
communauté scientifique partagent une
analyse semblable une minorité infime
d'experts rame à contre-courant du
consensus scientifique alimentant
parfois la désinformation
parmi eux le médecin marseillais didier
raoult grand apôtre de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine lui qui se trouve encore
cette semaine empêtré dans une
controverse
mary perd là ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine avec monsieur raoult dans ça
ressemble un véritable téléroman faut
bien dire haut et une tension dramatique
le quasi insoutenable sur twitter après
qu'une débusqueuse de fraudes aient
laissé sous-entendre que certains
travaux de didier raoult aurait pu être
falsifiés et ça donnait lieu d échange
très musclé entre les pros raoult et les
antis raul on peut presque parler d'un
grand schisme avec don d'un côté didier
raoult l'incarnation même du
scientifique dissidents un spécialiste
des maladies infectieuses c'est vraiment
une machine à publier les comptes des
milliers de publications à son actif le
sait presque surhumain ce rythme de
publication là et sans pousse plusieurs
même à remettre en question son
implication réelle dans tous ces travaux
là
des travaux qui ont été surtout connu du
grand public avec eux ces essais
cliniques sur l'idh roxy chloroquine il
ya beaucoup contribué à sa réputation de
remède miracle est celle qui a osé
s'attaquer à lui c'est elisabeth pique
une microbiologiste néerlandaise qui se
spécialise donc dans la détection
d'image frauduleuse dans des
publications scientifiques et
l'animosité entre ces deux là ça remonte
pas à la semaine dernière là des jeunes
elisabeth bic avait avait reproché entre
autres c'était vraiment attardé à ces
travaux justement sur l'idh roxy
chloroquine
repéré plusieurs erreurs méthodologiques
là-dedans là entre autres
elle lui reprochait d'avoir à peu près
écarter les résultats de certains
patients quand il donc à cadrait pas
avec les attentes
elle avait résumé ça assez
sarcastiquement surtout et earl en
parlant de résultats incroyables
si on laisse de côté les patients
décédés et effet tout ça nous amène au
18 mars dernier qu'est ce qui s'est
passé surtout était donc elisabeth byrs
a attiré l'attention sur d'autres
aspects préoccupants d'autres
publications la partition entre dans des
considérations assez pointu mais en gros
elle a comparé deux photos issues d'une
publication une semblait être la copie
conforme de la première mais agrémenté
de modification et au fil des échanges
entre initiés sur twitter on découvre
que la première photo a été publié sur
wikipédia
bien avant la publication scientifique
et et que donc la deuxième le ceux qui
s'y connaissent pour eux c'est flagrant
c'est bel et bien la première photo qui
a été photoshopée est assez mal
photoshop est semble-t-il leur paraît
que c'est assez grossit et que ça saute
aux yeux ça c'était un exemple il y en a
plusieurs autres qu'ils habitent big
détails sur papier qui est un site qui
répertorie les soupçons de manquements à
l'éthique soupçon il faut dire parce
qu'elle accuse personne de fraude mais
elle a quand même écrit aux revues qui
ont publié ces travaux là et demande des
explications
hélas partir de là ce a dégénéré raoult
est pas allé au front personnellement
mais un de ses collègues eric chabrière
vraiment endosser le rôle de porteur de
aïn on peut dire qu'il maîtrise assez
bien la technique trempe à la sauce
scientifiques à savoir plutôt que de
répondre par des faits à ce qui nous est
reproché pour démontrer que c'est faux
ben on préfère contre-attaqué souvent de
manière
à ces personnels bref on a d'en revenir
aux faits reprochés
pour finir par savoir s'il ya bel et
bien eu manipulation de données que ce
soit intentionnel ou simplement des
négligences au cours des derniers mois
vous avez été très nombreux à nous
interpeller au sujet de ces experts qui
comme le docteur house divergent
totalement de la communauté scientifique
mondiale
érigé en héros par certains encouragent
aux objecteurs de conscience par
d'autres comment éviter les pièges qui
nous sont tendues jean-françois que le
bonjour et bienvenue au détecteur au
jour ont fait appel à vous pour
décortiquer un peu ce phénomène des
experts appelons les dissidents alors
selon vos observations jusqu'à quel
point leur discours ont une prise sur
l'opinion publique d'une part et ça
c'est peut-être la partie la moins grave
c'est qu'il ya un public qui est déjà
acquis à ses causes l'autre vaccin par
exemple ou des choses comme cela que
vont défendre mais il ya une autre
partie du public qui est petit les pois
conspirationnistes qui peut-être un peu
plus dans des zones grises qui se
questionnent qui êtes un peu que mes 6
envoient eux avec un groupe qui étudient
puis un pied qui je me poste de
professeur universitaire chercheur en
microbiologie virologie quelque chose
comme ça c'est le e
ça va ça va leur dire ça va leur dire
d'un coup dont il ya vraiment quelque
chose le sait ça va vraiment pour eux ça
va être la lal la chose l'élément qui
veut les faire basculer de l'autre côté
qui va lecture et qui va emporter leurs
convictions et dans tout ça qu'est ce
qu'on peut donner comme comme outil aux
gens pour déterminer la crédibilité de
tel ou tel expert il faut aller voir
d'abord parce que les diplômés tous et
tous on retrouverait là une autre étape
après ce serait de 2 comparé ce que eux
disent avec ce que les autres
scientifiques qui ont une expertise à
peu près équivalente ce que août ans il
là on peut tous y voir et savoir faire
une espèce d'historique de ce que c'est
m ces scientifiques l'ont fait parce que
des fois pour certaines personnes je dis
pas que c'est que c'est le cas pour tout
le monde mais des fois pour certaines
personnes contredire prendre le contre
courant de tout le monde c'est des fois
ça
posture c'est un réflexe intellectuelle
ça fait partie de leur personnalité de
faire ça ça donne une idée de la
crédibilité de ses personnages le
l'inconvénient c'est que malheureusement
les c'est une job de moine souvent c'est
un job de moi de le faire
force est malheureuse mais monsieur
madame tout le monde n'ont pas toujours
le temps de le faire les médias ne le
font pas toujours malheureusement non
plus leur donne des tribunes des fois
des gens qui racontent qu'ils racontent
un peu n'importe quoi audi qui perd on
est plutôt d'avis qu'on a tous un niveau
de responsabilité citoyens médias
gouvernements parlons des médias est ce
que didier raoult par exemple a été
surexposés selon vous dans la sphère
médiatique étant donné toutes les
critiques dont il a fait l'objet
dans le cas de didier raoult a mon avis
oui très surexposé puis avait défendu la
chloroquine au départ sur une sur la
base d'une étude qui était très petit et
retraite dont la méthodologie très
boiteuse qui a été très très critiquée
dès le départ par des fidèles soit
beaucoup de médias ont ignoré cmc
avertissement parce qu'il était
populaire une espèce défaite trump je
pense
il faisait faire du rafting il amenait
de de l'audience il a mené déclic et
donc beaucoup de médias en france mais
pas seulement en france un peu un peu
partout dans le monde je pense qu'ils
ont surfé sur cette espèce de vague raul
comme certains médias ont surfé sur la
vague 30 en 2016 2017 et jusqu'en 2020
pour faire du pour faire de l'audimat
sont en tout cas les gens peuvent se
tourner vers nous pour nous poser leurs
questions et on fera humblement de notre
mieux
bah oui on va continuer à travailler
fort très bien merci beaucoup
jean-françois klich urvoy salut